hello and welcome to a special edition
of spectator tv
it's the morning after the night before
that is the bbc head-to-head debate
richie's phoenix versus liz trust there
was lots of talk in advance that
receives united needed a game-changing
performance
i'm katy pauls this is james forsyth and
we're going to discuss where he managed
to achieve them um james what's your
verdict
so i think both camps are actually
relatively happy with what happened last
night
uh i think the tsunami camp feel that
they got this point across that
if you the the trust policy implies much
higher interest rates you know he
repeatedly
at the beginning of the debate kept
saying pointing out that patrick minford
the economist is trusted cited talked
about five to seven percent interest
rates as being the
corey about i mean the trust camp feel
but the polls show that you know
basically
within the margin of error about who won
and they are relieved to have got
through that you know this yes there's
another debate tonight but this was in
prime time on bbc one
and i also think that they i i think
they also feel that because
uh russia's united pushed her hard it
now makes it kind of slightly easier uh
one trust supporting minister for
centuries this morning for her kind of
to to uh to take a slightly lower
profile on some you know in terms of
these kind of things because this debate
was was you know no one can say that
this did that debate was soft last night
sure and yeah it's interesting in the
sense that
definitely during the debate it did not
feel as though team trust were a
particularly happy bunch uh because of
richie's next frequent
interjecting into the conversation
and there were some briefing quotes
flying around then there was one saying
you know
effectively saying russia
should not be in government
um only and that was from a trust
spokesperson
only for i think a few minutes later
trust him off every single job if she
wins yeah and i think this duality is is
a potential issue for those trusts i
mean you saw this with penny more than
said to her during the great like do you
do one of those earlier do you lead your
campaign because there is a question
which is this trust always like to say
destroying a positive campaign and yet
sometimes her campaign team fly out with
quotes like the one you just mentioned
or
you know it's her supporters in the dean
doris who is he's i think
it's a crowded field but i think we
could probably agree that the dean doris
has been the most aggressive tory in
this contest so far
um and i think this is i mean in a way
one of this is one of the
the two horses is trying to ride at the
moment it's always a question about
whether she would have boris johnson in
her cabinet which is she is in in many
ways she is benefiting from the anger
but some of those closest to boris
johnson feel it or she's soon at because
he resigned and this trust did not
yet at the same time she doesn't want to
attach herself fully to that and so i
thought it was interesting that while i
was in the
uh which debate was in austin for
example itv debate she wouldn't raise
her hand and say i'll put borussians by
cabinet last night it took a long time
to get to that answer and i mean that is
in part because she she is trying to
keep together this coalition of you know
people are very across that boris
johnson has been removed
and this coalition of the people who
actively want her to be prime minister
yes and as you mentioned when it comes
to her you know
perhaps the figures in her camp who are
going viral and she will it's tricky to
know whether she is authorizing it
because it can be helpful to have
probably in a way an attack dog whether
an actual spokesperson or just
politicians coming out and saying things
you don't want to say in the debate
and therefore looking at nadine doris
yes and she is talking about this
truss's choice of claire's accessories
earrings whereas she said i've gone for
a really expensive suit
and
when there's trust was pressed on that
she she wouldn't really go against what
nadine dora said would she
yeah she kind of kept saying that she
hadn't seen it um she said she deleted
it from her phone twitter but i'm pretty
sure tweets are going out from her
account yes and also i think the other
point is this is that you know her team
are very professional there is no way
they would not have told her that had
been said before before she went on to
the unless they didn't tell her just so
she could
um yeah uh
and i think this is i think this is a i
think she does need to
she doesn't control this because i mean
one of the things we saw with boris
johnson was he used to to adopt a
slightly similar attitude when some of
the more um uh punchy quotes should we
say came out from people uh everybody
speaking rooms
not me don't know what it said
i i think that you can with the benefit
of hindsight say that that that is
clearly one of the things that did cause
borisov some problems in time i i think
if you are in if you are running a
campaign you do need to kind of take
charge of it in that way and say look
this is this is what we stand for this
is what
how how we're going to do this and
because i think there's also a point
here which is you know
there is still a kind of um
there is still a soreness i think on
behalf of some of the penny morgan
supporters about what happened to her
and i think you know
if his trust is to win this contest
she's going to be in tricky position
because he's going to be trying to pull
back a parliamentary policy together
when even in the final round now you can
say no no one break 40 but she didn't
break a third in terms of the votes and
so she and you know and so i think i
think in some ways one of the things
that that falls on her at the front run
is to start thinking a bit about how you
do that and it's harder to do that if
the private sensor there are these very
hyper aggressive quotes flying around
now we're going to get to a few of the
questions that are coming in uh shortly
but just
james it feels as though rishi sinek is
in a race against time in the sense that
all the polling suggests that this trust
is comfortably ahead the fact that both
camps were fairly happy with last
night's debate suggests that
it isn't a net win for richard sunic in
the sense that it isn't uh and perhaps
these moments are very hard to come by
and rarely come back but you know isn't
it gonna completely shake things up
where they were and the ballots go out
next week
lots of people know these politicians
already they've seen them for years
it is beginning to look quite hard for
them to turn it around now so i only in
politics all these moments when people
think this is is this going to be a
game-changing moment you know almost one
way to guarantee something isn't the
game changing is to say it's going to be
i mean i i i i i lost to have the number
of pmqs that we've sat through kb over
the years where people are like this is
the moment and and it rarely turns out
to be because because that that that is
the way of politics i i think i think
the big question is how quickly the tour
members return their balance now history
suggests that you know maybe half of
them will return them straight away i
was quite strong yesterday talking to
mps supporting
uh
both candidates and none so some people
use supporting candidates to be knocked
out some people support the the two
candidates still on the right
they said
and again he says this is not this is
not something i suspect that either camp
would be popping the champagne courts
about they they said that they they
detect among their members a certain
lack of enthusiasm right now
um
and they thought this would not
translate into a stampede to fill out a
ballot straight away
uh
some
one mp admittedly of a candidate who's
been defeated was speculating that they
thought turnout could actually be lower
you know we don't know how many members
the tourney party has or by the site of
services of this situation but their
their view is that turnout might
actually be quite a bit lower than
people expect because
that you this person was saying that you
know uh they had supported tom dugan
heart what they were saying you know
there have been a lot of excitement
around coming bad knock or penny morton
yeah
and that because these people weren't
there yet people haven't yet kind of
quite come to terms with and that you
know that hugo paul which is trust very
head also did show
that she was still the the the bad
knocker morgan was still ahead of both
soon i can trust in people's first
preferences so i i think we wait to see
how quickly people vote
um
uh but you know look obviously
no campaign wants to be behind and no
campaign wants me behind the voting
opening um as soon as it does in this
context now let's go through these
quickfire questions uh let me leave you
for this morning uh first will it hurt
this trust to not do the andrew neil
interview now rishi sunic has agreed to
do it that's on friday
so far all the mood music from the trust
camp is they don't plan to entertain it
um is that going to be damaging to her
boris johnson i mean didn't do such an
interview and still managed to get
through well i think he did do it and he
didn't do it in general actually he did
do it in the leisure contest
um
i i think what it does is it puts more
by not doing it you put more pressure on
your other performances because first of
all no other interviewer wants to look
like they're soft if you think back to
the 2017 general election when boris
johnson appeared on andrew marr's show
having not done andrew neal andrew marr
uh
it was normally a kind of sunday morning
interview
it it it was it was a far feistier
encounter than you would have expected
because i think andrew mann wanted to
say look don't do me because you think
i'm softer than andrew neil so i i think
it will i think it will increase
probably some of the ferocity of some of
the questions in the other interviews
i also think it will it i also think
that
um
it will put a skin tiller of doubt into
people's minds why don't you want to do
this you know if you want to be prime
minister of the united
and and you're not states to sit down
for half an hour and be interviewed on
on on live television by andrew neal
why not i think that that that question
will be there but i think
the boris johnson point boris johnson's
point you make as the fatally
if he was writing in the leadership
campaign but not uh effectively during
the general election so
does this mean uh if liz trusted prime
minister she wouldn't do in a general
election no i mean that said i mean that
is a question and that because it's
because the lower media there actually
probably a bigger issue i think
among storyboarding members in terms of
would that then damage your chances yeah
yeah no no no that's true um now can we
expect the leadership runners up to
explicitly endorse isla trust or sooner
or will they now remain non-aligned so
here we're talking penny morden tom
tegenhart
gary badenock
i think at the moment my
my sense is
that
you're seeing quite a lot of movement
among their key backers so
david davis came out for um
uh
which is united this morning
um
uh but i think among the top contenders
i suspect that some of them will they
will probably be inclined to keep their
powder dry um
when i was speaking to one of them about
what their thinking was and their
thinking was it's quite difficult having
run for office to suddenly turn around
and say well
see if it's not me how about this person
yeah particularly after you've been in
these the the final five been in debates
but they have been attacking
each other's policies so they would have
to somehow explain why on tv a week ago
uh you know kerry why should criticize
russia you know on coburn uh you know
fraud but now so he should be prime
minister or on this trust on why you
know tax cuts now were a bad idea but
now and so exactly so i i suspect that
uh i suspect there will be a kind of
inclination to
to kind of um
to
to keep quiet
um but we you know you never rule
anything out into a leadership contest
there's always quite a good motto
okay um now just going through the final
few questions
um
how much capital would the trust
campaign be able to get out of cena's
aggressive approach last night uh you
know he richard has been accused of
mansplaining my son
um
i think the question is how does it come
across to viewers at home i personally
think this man's planning language you
know
i i can't imagine that particularly goes
down
well to remember the questions whether
people felt bought but he was he was
interrupting too much or not yeah um but
i also think this you know
the the these
uh that there are two there are two
aspects here of this debate vista
relationship right one is what one might
call kind of
necessary
and always kind of good bloomberg which
is there is a big difference between the
economy and that does need to be debated
out and debated hard i would say and
then the question is who's who is the
biggest stature right which kind of goes
to your point there yeah and then the
the the second point is the kind of um
claire's accessories blue and blue i
mean that line can be discontinued about
any great loss to public debate in the
public realm um
i think the point is you've never
shopped in claire's uh
i have not no um the point i think in a
way although weirdly enough i actually
thought the moment the debate turned a
bit more civil was when that question
came up um
but i think in some ways the tory policy
shouldn't
i i don't quite see how you patch over
the fundamental difference between the
two of them on the economy question i
think i mean you do need to debate that
you do need to say well hang on a second
if you're going to loosen fiscal policy
to this extent and you claim it's not
going to be inflationary the quality of
that is going to have to be much tighter
monetary policy
but by that logic
there was it was a slightly bizarre
debate near the end when liz trust said
she would offer take her job in in her
cabinet if she wins a contest and rishi
cena appeared to imply or suggest the
same and vice versa
i mean
really if liz trust becomes prime
minister and rishi sunik has gone so
hard on the idea it could be awful for
many tory voters mortgages and it's
really it'd be very difficult for him to
accept a job in that cabinet
i mean there's two things you can say
one is in political parties you know
political parties have debates and come
to decisions and secondly that there are
there are jobs you know i think it would
be hard watching that debate to imagine
either them as each other's chancellor
for example yeah but i don't think it
would be impossible to imagine you know
uh them as each other's foreign
secretaries for example you know i mean
so i mean that the
it depends what the role is and it
depends to what extent
uh
you some ways um
[Music]
you you
to what extent the the i the defeated
one is prepared to say look we had a
debate about this as a party
i argued for this position i lost that
argument i respect the decision of the
party members
yeah i mean
and whether they feel comfortable doing
that or
now final question did trust manage to
come across more charming last night or
can she capitalize on a line that she
doesn't present slickly i almost think
both things are true and i think when
you mentioned that claire's accessory
exchange and liz trust oh she actually
thought she's here dressed very well i
thought you did see a bit more of her
sense of humor and there's a bit of
warmth between them whereas um
you know actually this more kind of icy
uh persona she can have and there were
moments when i saw that washed away but
yet the the round rib tools that she
offered me got was when she said that
she wasn't slick at these things and
that seemed to resonate with the
audience so i think that actually not
trying to be someone you're not sound
like i'm a life coach right now
but i think that is i think she's
perhaps finding the best way for her to
do these things or something you can
look uncomfortable doing media but i
think the question is there was a point
during theresa may's premiership but
everyone loved the fact that she you
know wasn't very polished that she
didn't you know go to the bars and then
they got to the point where it just
turned and people didn't so so
what might work for now it's it's hard
to know if people will keep thinking oh
that's what i want what do you think
james
i i think she okay i think she has got
she has done better
in every debate from the first event and
i think she actually benefits from the
fact that
i think what she found difficult in the
first debate was with inserting herself
into the debate which when it's a
one-on-one debate you don't need to do
um
i i think the challenge for her is this
which is as you say the theresa may
parallel is kind of instructive which is
you can get a certain benefit out of
what i don't do
politics
in that respect but then if you do then
if you do something that that goes
against that and that ultimately
the sin of theresa may i think was to
call the early election having said to
people repeatedly no no uh i'm a vicar's
daughter uh i'm not gonna have another
election because it was bad for the
country trust me trust me trust me and
then decide to go pronounce the election
and so i mean that that is the danger i
also think the other other
challenge
is this which is you know
there is a
but
how are you
you know
as prime minister
you are kind of in people's lives
for a long time and i think you've got
to have a
view of how you will
explain your case
on difficult days as well as good days
um how do you make your arguments i
think that you know that that question
will will come to the fore i think also
though that
there is a kind of there is a question
after uh
the
politics
looks now
different than it looks um
the the the parties always go for
something different from what went
before now i think what you should see
like i can listen to this is something
very different from what went before um
you know in that register is offering
kind of you know competent
professionalism and politics you know
it's hard to imagine him uh coming on
stage of his kind of show hanging out a
la boris johnson
i think this trust is trying to say
well with boris johnson you had all this
charisma and all this verbal dexterity
but
where did it get you in the end and so i
mean this is the question that
but you can come back to this thing
which is you know ultimately if the
tories wish to stay in power they do
have to win a general election and that
is going to involve uh you know
kind of a campaigning performance that
allows you to do that
and with that thank you james and thank
you for watching today and do join us
again for our next spectator tv and of
course the week in 60 minutes
which will be coming out
on thursday